Superhero movies have dominated the box office,
but it's rare for them to be honored with
nominations in the major Academy Awards categories
- let alone the biggest one of all.
With that in mind, here's a look at how Black
Panther made history, and how this marks a
turning point for the Oscars.
"This never gets old.”
We've all become accustomed to Marvel's refusal
to settle for superficial storylines in their
films.
There's no shortage of modern action movies
that end up feeling like little more than
an excuse to unload a pile of cash on CGI
and special effects.
The MCU, on the other hand, has figured out
how to combine large-scale effects with meaningful
plots, deep drama, and complex characters.
Nowhere is this more apparent than in Black
Panther.
Black Panther's onscreen arc started in Captain
America: Civil War, which led to the solo
film beginning with T'Challa already having
taken up the mantle of the hero of Wakanda.
Black Panther was still essentially an origin
story, marking the true beginning of the King
of Wakanda's story.
As the story unfolded it didn't skimp on the
drama, either, continuing to evolve T'Challa's
persona as he struggled with his past, revelations
regarding his father, and the repercussions
of long-held family secrets.
From personal storylines to the introduction
of Wakanda, the film's story was masterfully
told, and the film's nominations will only
pave the way for future superhero films of
the same caliber to earn the Academy's attention.
Even the best scripts can often feel pointless
if they aren't brought to life by quality
acting, and Black Panther knocked this one
out of the park in spades.
Front and center, of course, we have the lovable
yet tough Chadwick Boseman, who was able to
depict T'Challa as a character with a fierceness
of resolve.
But along with that he also brought a depth
of feeling, understanding, and complexity
that helped elevate the entire movie.
Of course, Boseman's supporting cast was also
filled with talented actors - modern cinema
staples like Andy Serkis, who played returning
villain Ulysses Klaue.
"You can go, but just don't tell anyone, alright?"
The film also featured up and coming stars
like Letitia Wright, who delivered a memorable
performance as T'Challa's sister Shuri.
And then there's Michael B. Jordan, whose
Killmonger isn't just impressive, he's heart-wrenching.
In just over two hours Jordan managed to create
a personality that rivals the multi-movie
character arc of Loki and the dramatic complexity
of Thanos.
Few would argue that the movie's long list
of quality performances was another crucial
factor that launched the film into the Academy's
ballots.
While acting, directing, and storytelling
are all aspects of the film weren't specifically
honored by the Academy Awards, a quick glance
at the various nominations continues to reveal
just how thoroughly the movie left its impact.
Two of the nominations came for Sound Editing
and Sound Mixing, and it racked up two more
for Original Score and Original Song.
The quartet speaks for itself.
The audible experience of Black Panther, from
the sound effects to the music, was superbly
executed.
"Wakanda forever!”
“Wakanda forever!”
Two more nominations were landed in the categories
of Production Design and Costume Design, both
of which speak to the film's impressive array
of scenery and clothing.
All of these recognitions are neatly wrapped
up with the Best Picture nomination which
puts a bow on one of the most accomplished
chapters in the MCU.
While arguments can be made for previous Marvel
films that might have been the first to receive
the honor of a Best Picture nomination, there's
no question that Black Panther deserved the
nod on its own merits.
It's hard to believe that heading into the
2019 Oscar ceremony, the DCEU had won more
Oscars than the MCU by a whopping score of
one to zero, with the lone win coming in the
form of Makeup and Hairstyling for everyone's
favorite Oscar-winner, Suicide Squad.
"...And?"
But, while the two comic universes have certainly
received the short end of the stick, there
have been a handful of awards over the decades
given to several superhero classics.
Perhaps the nearest and dearest to the heart
of Marvel fans was Spider-Man 2, which won
an award for its visual effects.
Several years before Suicide Squad, comics
fans were also thrilled to see The Dark Knight
win two Academy Awards - one for editing and
one for best supporting actor, an honor posthumously
given to Heath Ledger for his performance
as the Joker.
However, while the two awards were in many
ways a seminal moment for the superhero genre
in the Academy's history, perhaps the greater
impact came from the fact that the film wasn't
nominated for best picture.
The perceived injustice became a rallying
point for comic fans, in many ways helping
to pave the way for the achievement that Black
Panther finally realized.
It's this issue over Best Picture nominations
that has stuck in the craw of so many comics
fans over the years.
While there is at least a semi-reasonable
track record of nominations — and wins — for
technical categories like makeup, sound editing,
and special effects, there has always been
a serious lack of attention for comic book
adaptations in the Best Picture category.
While films like The Dark Knight began to
shift the conversation from an "if" to more
of a "when," the success of other genres should
be taken into account when tracing the path
leading to Black Panther's historic success.
For example, it was considered outlandish
when the classic animated film Beauty and
the Beast was nominated for Best Picture in
the early '90s.
And yet, since then we've seen films like
Up and Toy Story 3 follow in its footsteps,
proving that the premise isn't as important
as the heart that holds it up.
Then there's the fantasy epic Lord of the
Rings: Return of the King, which dominated
the 76th Academy Awards with a clean sweep,
winning all 11 of the Oscars it was nominated
for.
While comics trailblazers have done their
part over time, the "little victories" along
the way, like the success of Peter Jackson's
monumental trilogy of Tolkien adaptations,
have certainly helped reshape the landscape,
setting the stage for the Best Picture nomination
that finally took superhero movies to the
next level of acclaim.
After all, let's not forget that 2018's Best
Picture winner was a movie about a fish god.
Why not one about a guy who dresses like a
cat?
Another factor behind the gradual acceptance
of comic book and superhero-based movies comes
from a certain level of cinematic maturation
that has taken place over the years.
It's safe to say that past superhero films
have been, well, kind of cheesy.
The MCU has been a major factor in pushing
the genre to a more mature level.
After a long incubation period that saw characters
like Tony Stark, Thor, and Captain America
finding their stride, the modern concept of
a superhero movie has certainly come a long
way.
As the MCU has evolved, it's played on a bigger
canvas and grasped at loftier ambitions as
well as more complex character arcs.
This has naturally pushed the end product
to higher levels.
While that initial growth culminated with
Black Panther's recognition by the Academy,
it's only a matter of time before we see even
more mature, more accomplished superhero films
- and see more of them reach the Oscars podium.
There are many reasons Black Panther broke
through the barrier of acceptance with the
world's most prestigious awards ceremony.
The combination of timing and quality has
launched director Ryan Coogler's creation
into the spotlight as it vies for recognition
that has been denied to so many worthy superhero
films before.
The most exciting part about 2019's Academy
Awards, however, is what it might lead to
next.
The final acceptance of superhero movies as
awards-worthy entertainment has further opened
the doors for serious filmmakers and artists
to genuinely invest themselves into their
comics-to-screen adaptations - not only in
the hopes of garnering the adulation of the
fans, but of possibly winning a nice shiny
Oscar while they're at it.
There's only one thing to say to that kind
of future:
"Let the challenge begin."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.